I normally test the latest Beauty
releases but today I'm testing out the
most hyped products from the early 2000s
let's start with some face products you
know I had to include the Maybelline
Dream matte mousse Foundation I feel
like this was a lot of people's First
Foundation mine included the formula is
like this chunky mousse with a bunch of
little beads that mattify the foundation
I had to apply it with my fingers at
first of course this Foundation is just
really odd to me it doesn't look like
skin it doesn't look even it's kind of
drying and I can literally see the color
changing before my eyes I looked in the
mirror and I was straight up orange
which I guess is fitting for this era
loose powder mineral makeup was such a
big thing in the 2000s I've never tried
this Bare Minerals powder foundation
before but I was actually pleasantly
surprised I don't think it's as
buildable as it claims to be I feel like
wearing it sheer looks better than when
you keep layering it but I liked how
this looked on my skin it was wasn't too
drying but I did need a setting spray to
kind of melt it all in it feels
weightless which I really liked and
everything I put on top of this looked
nice this also has SPF in it and it's
talc free this one triggered me because
I remember trying to hide my acne with
this stuff this is the Maybelline cover
stick corrector concealer it's a very
thick formula it doesn't spread super
easily and I can like feel it on my skin
it actually did a decent job of covering
everything I needed it to cover but
concealer formulas have just gotten so
much better than this plus the shade
range is abysmal this one can stay in
the past bronzer usage was at an
all-time high in the 2000s and this one
was always a popular choice this is the
Nars Laguna bronzer it's a bronzer with
a bunch of gold Shimmer in it
surprisingly this looks pretty smooth on
the face even on top of that Maybelline
mousse Foundation I thought that and the
Shimmer in it would emphasize all of my
texture but it didn't it also didn't
look orange which I was also nervous
about I also tried the classic Ben
Benefit Cosmetics hula bronzer this one
also applies very smoothly it has no
Shimmer in it which I prefer I believe
back then benefit only had this one
shade which was a little light for me
the shade range still hasn't expanded
very much but this formula has held up
this is the iconic Nars blush in the
shade orgasm it's a peachy pink with a
ridiculous amount of gold Shimmer in it
it claims to be buildable but the more I
layered this for that very 2000s pink
blush look the more textured my skin
looked like this highlighted everything
it's weird because I applied a lot of
the bronzer too which also has Shimmer
in it and it didn't look like this this
blush is just not for me the Urban Decay
primer potion is a tried and true
favorite the formula is thinner than
other eyeshadow bases I've tried I used
a super cheap Covergirl eyeshadow on top
of this and I feel like it actually made
it look way better it makes it easy to
blend out Shadow I feel like it
intensifies the color this is way
overpriced but I think this is a solid
eyeshadow primer I saw so many of these
Covergirl eye enhancers in my research
for this video they are just as chalky
as they look the colors I chose may be
the reason why but I can't talk about
2000's makeup without some Frosty blue
and white eyeshadow I think if I hadn't
used them on top of that Urban Decay
primer potion they just would have not
shown up look at these swatches on the
back of my hand just awful I will say
that these little sponge applicators
that I used to always throw away
actually apply the eyeshadow pretty well
now these I still use all the time these
are the Nyx jumbo eye pencils you can
use them for so much as an eyeshadow as
a base for eye shadow as an eyeliner
these got like a new life because of
tick tock people were using them to
highlight certain areas of the face the
formula is just super creamy and easy to
work with it is kind of a pain to
sharpen when you need to but I like the
formula so I just deal with it I also
still use and really like this product
this is the Urban Decay heavy metal
glitter eyeliner this does dry down
quickly so you want to work fast but I
think it has the prettiest Sparkle to
the eyes it's an easy way to use glitter
without any mess I will say this doesn't
layer very well though it can get flaky
if you layer it too much this is the max
smolder eyeliner I had to try this
specific eyeliner because Avril Lavigne
said she used to use this one all of the
time I don't typically like wooden
eyeliners but this one applied really
well I have very sensitive eyes so my
waterline gets super watery when I try
to apply eyeliner but the pigment
actually stuck with this one I actually
used to love the Maybelline great lash
mascara I think the formula is pretty
good it doesn't give a ton of length but
it gives a nice amount of volume without
getting clumpy I honestly think if it
had a different brush I'd like it more
in a sea of drugstore mascaras I don't
think I'd go back to this one but I
appreciate it for what it is doo-wop lip
Venom is like the OG lip plumper the
tangle with this is pretty strong so if
you hate that feeling I would avoid this
it has this really nice cinnamony scent
and it gives a really nice shine I like
that it's a clear shade that you can put
on top of anything I noticed the
Plumping more on my top lip but it
definitely plumps and I noticed that it
also made my lips look a bit smoother
MAC lipsticks were so popular in the
2000s myth was like the concealer lip
shade it's this super pale nude that
looks ridiculous on me without a lip
liner and snob is this pale pastel pink
color that reminds me of Nicki Minaj
also looks awful on me aside from the
questionable color choices the max satin
lipstick formula still holds up it's
comfortable on the lips and the formula
is pretty buildable also the vanilla
scent of MAC lipsticks always takes me
back this is the Mac lip liner in spice
I loved this this lip liner formula
applies really smoothly it doesn't dry
down too quickly so you have time to
blend I tried to do a super defined lip
liner look with that myth lipstick and I
actually loved it I'm definitely gonna
keep using this I've waited my whole
life to try the Mac lip gloss this is
very thick I will say I personally love
the feeling of a thick gloss I love how
cushiony it is but you definitely feel
this on the lips I know why they call it
lip gloss because the shine this gives
is unreal I'm in love with this I also
tried a Lancome juicy tube which is like
the arch nemesis to the Mac lip gloss I
picked this color because it looks just
like the one that Gretchen Wieners uses
it has a scent I really dislike it's
kind of floral perfumey the actual
formula is nice it's thinner than the
lip gloss but still really shiny and
pretty I don't think this is anything
that special the Nars lip gloss in
Turkish delight feels very 2000s it's
this pale milky pink color I think this
used to be Kim Kardashian's favorite
gloss which I don't know why this
formula is kind of oily and thin I don't
know if it used to be a different
formula but it's not very good now this
color also settles into the wrinkles on
my lips so it's just not super
flattering I could not do a 2000s makeup
video without mentioning lip smackers
lip glosses they're more like a lip
gloss for kids like my mom bought me
these before I was allowed to wear any
makeup they're not actually a good lip
gloss formula they feel like chicken
grease on the lips but you know what
they still smell and taste just as good
as you remember I would never buy these
as a serious lip gloss option but using
them again has brought me so much joy
foreign
[Music]